j'ai pas vu ton front depuis au moins 15
ans peut arrêter avec ça dirait que tu
vis dans les années 60 et nous c'est
quoi ça les années 60
aujourd'hui c'est maman je voulais juste
te dire 'ne t'inquiète pas détends toi
qui vas y arriver je le sais je t'aime
messages archivés en gros pour mon père
la vie est tout simplement une suite de
problèmes à résoudre
et sa manière d'aborder le deuil
n'échappe pas à cette règle j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi je vais vendre la
maison est comme ça un peu rapide alors
comment serait il ya deux couples qui
porte à perrine affres et maintenant je
l'annonçais monfils au fond du trou en
ce moment tu devrais venir
il faut juste pas toute la maison il
faut qu on décide ensemble vendredi
je peux pas vendredi pourquoi
je vais en californie
créatif bon je vais être direct on adore
tes dessins très simples comme ceux d'un
gosse excusez moi je vous interromps
juste une minute
bougez pas merci désolé pas me résoudre
à bosser avec des gens qui se qualifie
de créatifs tu dois être hyper créatif
ça soit tout de suite au non de boulot
qui était trouvé c'est super créatif
toi et moi ce soir on sort et je vais te
montrer ce que tu as raté à brooklyn
soit un petit peu plus spontané ça ira
beaucoup
ramassez grave j'ai tout vu que j'étais
c'est gentil de ouais d'accord ok j'ai
passé une bonne soirée aussi
l'endroit où tu es et j'ai besoin que tu
reviennes ce que je veux c'est me sortir
de ce brouillard je veux arrêter de
parler de la vie et de la mort
[Musique]
quand on perd un proche et se ressentir
une immense solitude mais ça ne veut pas
dire que tu ne te remettra jamais
et vous comment je m'appelle dean
[Musique]